翻訳: uchiyama yuka
校正: Tetsuya Kawaguchi
小学1年生のころに
初めて出場した相撲大会で
私は相撲に魅了されました
自分より大きい子や 男の子に勝ったときの
周りの歓声が嬉しくて
何よりも１対１の勝負で勝てることが嬉しくて
私は大学３年生になった今でも
相撲を続けています
しかし 私は大きな壁にぶつかりました
高校時代の右肩の怪我が原因で
お医者さんから
手術をするか 相撲をやめるか
という２つの選択肢を与えられたのです
なぜ私が相撲を続けるという
選択をしたか
それは何よりも
相撲が好き
という気持ちがあるからです
その気持ちがあるから
今まで ぶち当たってきた壁を
今まで 練習を重ねてきた自分
そして 未来の自分のために乗り越え
世界制覇という夢を
叶えたい自分がいるのです
幼い頃から私は
レスリング 相撲 柔道を行い
現在大学では 女子相撲において
世界一を目指し 日々稽古をしています
皆さんは女子相撲と聞いて
どんなイメージを持っていますか？
こちらの動画をご覧ください
（歓声）
（シャッター音）
（かけ声）
集中 集中
（行司）はっけよい
よしよし！
これが女子相撲です
レオタードを着用した上に まわしを巻き
ルールは男性のアマチュアの相撲と
基本的には同じで行われています
相撲は1500年前から
日本で行われてきた伝統競技で
それは 少しずつ形を変えてきました
相撲というと男性のスポーツ
大相撲のように大きな力士のぶつかり合いを
想像される方が多いと思います
しかしアマチュアでは
男性だけではなく
女性も相撲を取ることができるのです
女子相撲は階級別の試合と
無差別級の試合があるのも 特徴のひとつです
階級は 超軽量級 軽量級 中量級 重量級の
４つに分かれ
それぞれに魅力があります
無差級の試合は
時には100キロ差の選手同士が
試合をすることもあり
選手それぞれが 様々な思考を巡らして
相撲を取るところが興味深いです
小学１年生のとき
私はレスリングに出会いました
私の家族はプロレスが大好きで
幼い頃から家族でプロレス観戦に行くことが
私の家族の一大イベントであり
格闘技が身近にあることが当たり前でした
３つ離れた兄が
「レスリングをやりたい」と言い出し
私も一緒に見学に行きました
最初はレスリングを
習うつもりは ありませんでしたが
母と兄が 練習の後に
外食に行っているのが羨ましくて
食につられて 私もレスリングを始めました
そのレスリングのチームで
出場することになったのが
最初にお話しした 相撲大会です
相撲に魅了された私は
その大会には 毎年出場するようになり
小学６年生では
初めて全国大会に出場しました
結果は２回戦負け
周りのフォローは一切響かず
ただただ 悔しかった気持ちでいっぱいでした
大会前 相撲は小学生でおしまいかな？
と思っていたのですが
好きな相撲で負けた という悔しさが
私の相撲人生を延長させました
中学生になり 部活動で柔道も始め
レスリング 相撲 柔道の
三足の草鞋を履くようになり
毎日 何かしらの
格闘技をやるようになりました
１週間 ほぼ休みなしの生活です
そして迎えた相撲の全国大会
軽量級の中でも 最軽量での出場で
応援に来ていた両親も 半ばあきらめ状態の中
自分より大きい選手をどんどん負かし
準優勝
中学校２年生での全国大会では 初優勝
翌年の全国大会でも連覇をしました
高校生になり
より相撲に打ち込むようになりました
しかし レスリングや柔道を
やめてしまったわけではありません
相撲の基本となるのは 押し相撲ですが
私の相撲の基となるのは
スピードとねばり強さ
そして 相手の力や
勢いを利用する力です
それは レスリングや柔道から得た技術です
スピードがあることで
自分の形や 自分のペースで
相撲をとることができます
自分が不利な体勢になっても
粘り強さがあれば 最後まであきらめず
タイミングを見計らって技をかけ
自分の形に持っていくことができます
相手の力を利用してフェイントをかけたり
投げ技を決めたりすることができます
高校生活最後の年に
高校３年間で目標にしていた
女子相撲ジュニア世界選手権の
代表選手になり
出場しました
初めての世界大会で 会場の空気に馴染めず
プレッシャーに
押しつぶされそうになりながらも
家族やチームメイトのフォローに助けられ
駒をすすめることができ
迎えた決勝戦
立ち合いから 私の頭を落とそうとした
相手の懐に すばやく飛び込み
足を取り 相手を倒し
世界の頂点に立つことが出来たのです
この結果を出せたのは まさしく
レスリングや柔道の経験があったからです
いままでの レスリング 相撲 柔道における
集大成と感じられるような相撲内容で
もちろん 結果にも満足でしたが
私がこの３つの競技を
こだわってやってきたことに
自信を持つことができた大会でした
中学生までレスリングを中心にやり
柔道もやり
なぜ最終的に選んだのが 相撲だったのか
誰もが疑問に思うことだと思います
答えは簡単です
相撲が一番勝てるようになったからです
私はこの３つの競技を
やってきたからこそ
相撲において結果が出るようになり
この３つの競技をやってきたからこそ
相撲を最後に絞ることができたと思います
レスリング 柔道は
オリンピック競技ですが
女子相撲は
存在すら知らない人々も 多くいます
観客の視線が集まる
緊張感あふれる土俵の上に立ち
相手と自分のタイミングで始まる立ち合い
そこからは 逆転のできない一瞬の勝負です
レスリング 柔道がポイント制なのに対し
相撲は 足以外が地面についたら
土俵の外に出たら 負けです
一瞬で一発勝負だからこそ
土俵の上では何が起こるかわかりません
体格の小さい選手が
大きい選手を負かすことは少なくありません
それは相撲が 力技だけではなく
タイミングやスピードも
兼ね備えているスポーツだからだと思います
レスリングや柔道は階級が細かく分かれており
軽量級の選手から 重量級の選手が
全員参加する無差別級の試合は
国際的な大会では見たことがありません
しかし 相撲では 力や重さ以外の要素も
勝敗に大きく影響するため
無差別級の試合でも
軽量級の選手が勝ち上がることが
可能なのではないかと思います
また 絶対勝つと思われていた選手が
負けてしまうこともあります
それは相撲が 一瞬の勝負である分
精神的な影響力が大きく出るからです
期待されればされるほど
プレッシャーも大きくなり
その中で戦うのは
相手であり 自分自身でもあります
このように相撲は 単純なルールですが
入り込めば入り込むほど奥深く
私もまだ 答えに辿り着いていません
わたしはジュニアの部門で
世界チャンピオンになりました
しかし その上にはシニアの部門があり
そこには大きな差が存在します
私はシニアの部門でも
世界チャンピオンになりたいと
日々 稽古をしています
と同時に 世界に女子相撲を発信したいと
強く思うようになりました
女性が相撲をするということは
意外でも特殊でも何でもありません
ただ 相撲というイメージが
「体の大きな男性が行う」という
固定概念が邪魔をしているだけで
私は相撲が １スポーツとして
認められるべきだと思います
相撲が男女関係なく
誰もが楽しめるスポーツになってほしい
そして 世界的に競技人口が増え
オリンピック競技になってほしい
というのが 私達競技者の夢です
最初の方で皆さんに
女子相撲と聞いてどんなイメージを
持っていますか とお聞きしました
イメージは変わったでしょうか？
シニアの世界チャンピオンを目指す選手として
一瞬の勝負の力強さ そして儚さを
私はこれからも突き詰めていきたい
そして 女子相撲というスポーツを
皆さんに伝え 広めていきたいです
（拍手）